[Musique]
pour la 8e fois une fusée américaine
Delta a placé sur orbite un satellite
tiros un de ces satellites
météorologiques équipé de caméras pour
enregistrer l'image des nuages et la
mettre aux stations terrestre mais c'est
la première fois que la France avec le
Centre d'études et télécommunications de
l'anon participe à cette nouvelle
technique de la prévision du
temps la station de l'anon compte
désormais parmi les 55 stations équipées
pour recevoir les photos prises à 1500
km d'altitude par Tyros 8 qu'une antenne
guettete dans le
ciel dans sa course autour de la Terre
qui lui permet de balayer toute la
surface du globe le satellite passe
plusieurs fois dans la zone de visite
bité de la nion et lors de ses passages
dans cette zone les photos qu'il prend
peuvent être capté par le Centre
Français sur ordre de la terre l'antenne
spéciale reçoit les signaux émis par
Tyros et ces signaux sont alors
transformés en photographie par un
système analogue au traditionnel
[Musique]
bellinographe ce n'est alors plus qu'un
jeu pour les météorologistes de situer
sur une carte à l'aide d'une grille
correspondante à la photographie les
formations nuageuses qui intéressent
toute une
région ici par exemple celle qui va du
golfe de Gascogne au Maroc ainsi
pourra-t-on procéder de proche en proche
et de station en station et finalement
obtenir la carte complète des nuages qui
entourent le globe pour une région
donnée comme ici la péninsule ibérique
des enregistrements successifs
permettront de connaître l'évolution des
masses nuageuses et du même coup d'en
déduire la prévision du temps
les précédents tios ont déjà permis de
repérer de terribles cyclones et
d'avertir la population 24 heur avant
leur manifestation avec tiros suite la
météo dispose aujourd'hui d'une arme
encore plus
[Musique]
perfectionnée la mode parisienne est
entrée dans l'année la nuque basse
c'est-à-dire qu'elle a réadopté le
catogan cette F ravissante qui fut une
part du style 18e mais bien sûr un
catogan rajuni renouvelé ainsi le
catogan de Jacques
[Musique]
deessange et celui d'Antoine Salvador
d'une audacieuse
[Musique]
fantaisie celui de Pierre Charby
classique dans sa jeunesse
[Musique]
d'expression et enfin celui si pur et si
saayant sans nœud ni cocarde de Jacques
[Musique]
Dour le joli retour du
katogan le calendrier des postes que
selon une tradition toujours cherment
appréciée les préposés d'aujourd'hui
dans leur costume modèle 63 sont venus
offrir pour la nouvelle année à
maintenant 110 ans depuis 1854 date de
sa naissance il semble avoir mis un
point d'honneur à se faire dans un style
changeant mais toujours très particulier
le reflet disons de l'histoire de la
famille impériale à nos jours en passant
par la guerre de 70 pendant et après il
a imposé dans chaque famille sa vision
sommaire des événements et de la vie
[Musique]
quotidienne avec les tram à chevaux des
Champs-Élysées et le lac hdilque du bois
de Boulogne c'est la vie sans souci de
la fin du siècle dernier le temps des
rendez-vous à la cascade de beaux
messieurs moustachu à cheval et de jolie
femmes en calèche c'est aussi le temps
béni des casinos et des rassemblements
fièvreux autour du tapis
[Musique]
vert 1900 on vient voir et complimenter
l'armée
française voici le temps des Vals et des
volants
le temps des bains de mer à la mode les
mécaniques commencent à impressionner
sérieusement les jolies promneuses la
petite reine conquier le beau sexe et
lui apporte des sensations
nouvelles et puis c'est 1914 la jumelle
rivée sur la ligne bleue desvuge le
défenseur de la patrie fière allure
comme les compagnies cycliste du début
de la guerre jusqu'à l'apparition du
bleu horizon qui créera la silhouette du
poilu et attendra 4
ans 1925 c'est l'image de la femme au
volant et de la garçonne le temps d'un
Charleston en attendant d'arriver à
l'autre guerre celle à qui ses engins
donnaient une allure d'apocalypse
croyait-on celle aussi dont l'exode est
resté dans les
mémoires et puis viendront les
calendriers de la
[Musique]
Libération
aujourd'hui le calendrier qui tire à 15
millions d'exemplaires semble faire
quelques concession au style américain à
faire d'époque depuis 110 ans il fait ce
qu'il peut pour suivre son temps ce
brave
calendrier bien qu'il n'y ait pas de
neige cette année dans les Alpes les
skilleuses Françaises sont déjà prêtes
pour les Jeux Olympiques d'insbrook au
Salom spécial de grindelvald malgré l'
r
l'amain l'ANT s SK féminin français
aorté nouvelle victoires de cette ée Mar
jou des héroes il lui subir un véritable
chemin de
croix aprèso he un piqu avec une j au
cours de la première manche la petite
championne a d ensite éviter un officiel
qui malencontreusement éta tombé sur la
MIR a qu mme Gagné comm gagner peut-tre
les jeux
Olympi
au cours du lobound à vengen
l'autrichienen Zimerman et l'allemand
Lud schner sont partag les lauers la
victoire de que l'on voit ici dans le
slalom spécial est tiré par les cheveux
aussi bien son sourire après l'arrivée
est un peu crispé parce qu'il doit sa
victoire à la disqualification douteuse
disonsle du français gu les juges on dit
manqué une porte ontil raison regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien
il semble si l'on en juge par ce
document que gu per n'est pas avalé la
porte apparemment il est bel et bien
passé entre les de piquets quoi qu'il en
soit déclassé ou non après cette course
Pera est l'un des favoris numéro 1 du
slalom spécial des Jeux
Olympiques et c'est sans pour cela qu'il
est sans rancune contre son vainqueur
inattendu ludwiig schner qui l'a quand
même
félicité au haw c'est le printemps toute
l'année la plage de mahaka c'est une
espèce de paradis terrestre un paradis
pour touristes riches en dollars mais
les rois de mahaka ce ne sont pas les
milliardaires ce sont les champions du
surfing rien n'empêche d'être
milliardaire pour pratiquer le surfing
mais la qualité majeure pour un champion
de cette spécialité c'est surtout
l'audace et la souplesse et ce n'est pas
toujours suffisant pour éviter les vins
forcés quoi qu'il en soit faire du
surfing en plein hiver comme ces haw
c'est un luxe qui fait rêver tout le
monde et bien regardons et
rêvons
et vive le surfing ça c'est du
sport
[Musique]